Here's the filled in version of the table. You'll notice that we did end up with
one spot in this far right column where we had to write undefined and that was
where x equals 4. We set x equal to 4, the denominator here becomes 0. And since
we know that division is not allowed, it's not something we can interpret using
our algebra skills, you have to write undefined in this box. It makes the entire
fraction, the entire rational expression undefined. Whereas, when we were
dealing with quadratic inequalities, we were multiplying two factors together.
Now, we're dividing them. But what's interesting to note is that we have the
same relationship between signs of the first two columns and the sign of the
third column. If we're dividing two negative numbers, we get a positive number.
If we're dividing a negative by a positive or the reverse, a positive by a
negative, we get a negative number. And if we're dividing two positive numbers,
we get a positive. Of course, zero is the exception, 0 divided by any number,
regardless of positive or negative, is 0. And any number, whether positive or
negative divided by 0, is going to give us an undefined answer.